[Music]
following Parliament's declaration of a
climate emergency MEP s will vote on a
series of measures to help tackle the
crisis this will include a European
Green Deal to create jobs and
sustainable growth and steps to reduce
co2 emissions from aviation and shipping
all of this with the aim of reaching net
carbon neutrality by 2050 Parliament
will vote on proposals to ensure that
Europe remains a leader in the digital
world upcoming legislation will protect
people from discrimination by algorithms
update laws on e-commerce look at how to
use big data for innovation and promote
artificial intelligence while ensuring
it's properly regulated Parliament will
continue to fight for its priorities in
the --use 2021 to 2027 budget MEP s want
more funds for the environment the
single market and innovation and
increased spending on external borders
and migration in the event of protracted
negotiations Parliament wants to ensure
he you supported projects and erasmus+
exchange programs receive funding to
begin on time in 2021 the European
banking union was born in the wake of
the eurozone crisis Parliament will
examine the next steps to completing the
banking Union this will include a
Deposit Insurance Scheme to protect
people savings and a backstop to the
single resolution fund the insurance
policy in the event of a bank failure
Parliament will look at how to improve
the rights of people who travel by train
in particular those with disabilities or
reduced mobility the rules will ensure
passengers are better informed of their
rights and that complaints are quickly
resolved Parliament will vote on a new
trade agreement with Vietnam in early
2020 the deal would eliminate 99% of
tariffs between Vietnam and the EU MEP
swamped the deal to bring positive
change to Vietnam
including improvements to human and
labor rights and support for climate
action Albania and North Macedonia have
both met the requirements to begin EU
accession talks MEP said in October
Parliament said it was disappointed EU
members had failed to agree to start
those talks the debate on the accession
of Western Balkan nations will continue
in Parliament Montenegro Serbia Bosnia
Herzegovina and Kosovo are also hoping
to join the EU
[Music]